welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
latest trailer for marvel's doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
which assures us i will always be there
old friend
check me we are getting an mcu
illuminati lineup including patrick
stewart charles xavier what is this
movie i gotta admit i've outdone myself
on this one folks analyzing this trailer
frame by frame for details i don't think
anyone else is insane enough to see or
to talk about and uh yeah i'm also gonna
include some stuff in the tv spot
version of the trailer and clues in the
official poster and thanks to true bill
for sponsoring today's video more on
them later let's get started
every night
i dreamed the same dream
then
so the trailer opens in strange's
nightmare a frightening hellscape
covered in bones and skulls dead trees
bent askew and in front of him a
representation of the sanctum sanctorum
melting into inky nothingness like the
other new york buildings we saw in the
first trailer all evoking the comic book
ink melting of reality and what if
episode 4 except that this isn't exactly
strange's sanctum it's significantly
thinner than we last saw in spider-man
no way home and it is one floor taller
the effect is a more gaunt structure
like a croaking haunted hotel what was
his healthy sanctum fortress is now a
withering skeleton of itself and notice
in the sky is a glowing red eye
reminding us of course of the red edges
of wanda maximoff's hex reality and one
division this whole nightmare could be
being projected into strange's mind by
the scarlet witch since the commercials
in wanda vision were confirmed to be
messages from strange to wanda these two
share a psychic link now this strange
has a patch of blue sewn into the cloak
of levitation an inverse of the red
patch on blue of defender strange who
saves america chavez in a second blue
versus red seems to be an important
point of contrast in this film strange
has been shifted from his normal red
tones to blue tone along with a lot of
the settings in this to signal passivity
all to contrast wanda maximoff's red
chaos and violence now on the other side
of the sanctum doors there's a reverse
shot of strange's entrance from the
first trailer now we see how the stormy
sea has claimed the whole sanctum
structure saved for the central
staircase which now extends up and up
and up into nowhere like a trick luring
one to heaven except it's not it goes
into this hellish red eye and at the
base of the staircase these weren't
there the pastimes we saw the sanctum
now these two statues one male one
female both bearing torches may be
representing the maximoff twins then a
teacup shatters on the ground behind it
looks like the wheel of an old
wheelchair now this isn't exactly the
wheelchair professor x from the x-men
films but i suspect a lot is going to be
changing for whatever cameos show up in
this film then america chavez gets
strung up in front of a star portal
which if you look closely opens up to
endless more star portals within that
portal this is our best known power to
kick open these star-shaped portals we
might actually be seeing the origin of
our powers right here we actually saw
the same setting in the first trailer i
think it is her home reality the utopian
parallel in the comics the utopian
parallel faces destruction from black
holes so her mothers sacrificed
themselves their particles dispersing
throughout the multiverse and the
creature attacking her here maybe go
with me on this the demiurge who is the
embodiment of earth's sentient life in
the comics the original source of her
powers and we should mention is one
final form of billy kaplan wiccan wanda
maximov's son which could be how this
film ties the fate of wanda and her sons
to that of american chavez then again
the demiurge hasn't really been shown to
be this hostile and demonic actually
another possibility here this entity's
ribbony appearance like glowing
electrical tape could connect to
strange's spell the crimson bands of
citrax which he used to restrain thanos
and infinity war which could make this
fella maybe citrac himself now the tv
shot actually showed in this moment an
alternate defender doctor strange hair
tied back in a ponytail with stripes
saving america chavez from this thing
using what looks like a
three-dimensional version of strange's
normal flat eldritch magic to hold off
the entity which would then lead to the
shot we see in this trailer of that same
ponytail doctor strange tumbling through
a star portal a shot that flips upside
down to find us back with our doctor
strange in bed but is it our doctor
strange because his hands are fully
healed when in past films strange's
hands are always meant to be forever
scarred and weak there's an ipad left
open on his bed coffee filters into test
tubes on his nightstand strange said in
this part of the trailer that he has the
same dream every night hell sanctum his
alternate self saving a kid and then the
nightmare begins so the nightmare might
be this reality that he wakes up into a
reality where he never became a sorcerer
he never injured his hands and really
just aged into a lonely douchebag
falling asleep with its pornhub tab
still open moving on the nightmare
begins
i did what i had to do
now when strange says the nightmare
begins we should also acknowledge the
possibility that the demonic entity
nightmare could be the villain of this
film as this idea was floated by the
original director scott derrickson the
marvel studios title card turns purple
and has tentacles snaking across the
letters evoking the limbs of gargantos
but also one of the multi-limbed
creatures and what if which this movie
seems to be showing the live-action
versions of in fact on the poster for
this film in the lower right corner one
broken shard of glass shows the shield
of captain carter hinting that haley
atwell may show up in this film as a
live-action version of that character
then dr strange conjures these red orbs
if you look closely they are coming from
the dark hole on the floor there that's
marvel lore's book of the damn that
appeared on wanovision first in agatha's
possession before it was claimed by
wanda that's why the magic he conjures
is now red like wanda's chaos magic as
we saw her conjuring in that final wanda
vision scene we could be seen a
depiction of the various universes being
connected in this movie with dr strange
trying to locate one world in particular
and in the foreground of that shot that
looks like that is one of maximoff
standing there with him but then strange
suddenly afraid slams all this magic
back into the book as if he's trying to
hide it from the person in the room with
him and on that page you can see a
triangle perhaps a symbol of marvel's
illuminati a location he wants to hide
from wanda maximov for reasons i'll get
to later as we move on to protect our
world
you can control everything strange
you open the doorway between universes
and we don't know who or what will walk
through it
so strange argues that he did what he
had to do to protect our world our world
as in his actions saved his universe at
the expense of all other universes
strange used the time stone to give his
universe an improper advantage to undo
thanos's snap and more recently he used
his magic of the runes of cough call to
basically gaslight and warp society into
a whole bunch of plot holes mordo warned
us about this that when strange would
push the laws of reality like this the
bill comes
due
always and like strange in that what-if
universe bypassing an absolute point
this strange's reality has begun to melt
the same exact way and opened itself up
to interdimensional threats we see a new
look at this melting from the rooftop
individual bricks breaking off cars
floating in that blizzard headlights
still shining now the melting of the
buildings here seems to merge into these
black strands reminding us of the
ancient one's dark branch timeline that
she warned bruce banner about an endgame
and here it's not just that reality is
melting into nothing but that chaos is
spinning into one beneficiary
destination on to the next clip
wanda
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
he was right
so we see scarlet witch once again
holding the seance in the comartaj
courtyard we know that's where it is
because you can tell from the statues
behind her in the floor beneath her the
same tiling that we see beneath that
minotaur sorcerer later we get a better
look of him in this trailer this is
rantra from the comics but yes the
scarlet witch is probably the one
attacking kamertage because actually in
the tv spot the sorcerers in that
courtyard race their shields to some
floating figure overhead i'm pretty sure
that is wanda now compared to her look
at the end of wanda vision during the
seance her scarlet witch wardrobe has
evolved her sleeves now cover her arms
fully and darker tones streak through
her chest piece and her tiara also as we
pointed out before the tips of her
fingers are black similar to agatha's
fingers when she would use dark magic
and i like this right as we hear strange
say wanda a shock wave blows out from
her body now in her orchard if that is
what it really is wanna tell strange
that vision had theories about the
multiverse that was dangerous so despite
vision warning wanda she still created
an alternate reality in that westview
hex and now continues to peer through
alternate universes to find her children
and yes this peaceful orchard with sheep
is probably an illusion because later in
the trailer as wanda points out the
double standard of strange breaking the
rules and him getting to be a hero
strange is wearing the same outfit as he
is here in the orchard suggesting that
wanda is actually in a much darker place
in this moment both in her mindset and
in her literal surroundings moving on
i'm sorry stephen
your desecration of reality
will not go unpunished
so strange brings america chavez and
christine palmer to the ruins of what i
think is utopian parallel and christine
wears this sleek blue outfit and that's
because this might actually be an
alternate christine palmer whom strange
found working at illuminati hq because
the tv spot reveals christine in these
clothes plus a white lab coat in their
detainment sector then mordo or perhaps
an alternate version of mordo that might
actually be sorcerer supreme from his
native reality detain strange using
these nifty
love the design of these because it's a
mix of analog sorcerer machinery with
runes engraved into that spinning lock
in the middle but overall they have this
chunky silver chrome of something more
futuristic something that might be
connected to the vibranium tech of these
ultron sentries ultron centuries who
escort dr strange in this awesome
location that looks like a supreme court
hall of justice you see four kneeling
winged statues and then a warrior with a
sword in a ring the way a certain
multiversal warrior captain carter
emerged from a circular portal with her
sword in hand now this whole interior
the glass ceiling the curved staircases
the classic columns is actually the
interior of the british museum in london
a place i've been to many times i love
the british museum it's famous for
having the rosetta stone one of the
earliest artifacts that anthropologists
have used to translate and decode
cross-reference old languages which is
super fitting for charles xavier to
model his multiversal nexus point on
such a cultural touchstone now assuming
this is illuminati hq i find it
fascinating the parallels between this
and the citadel of he who remains in
loki which also had a lit tower inner
columns and four statues in its central
chamber one of which was mysteriously
destroyed we never got an answer to what
that was all about now there are six
chairs on the illuminati panel but we
only see three members in this trailer
could kang have been a fourth member of
the illuminati who was cast out leading
to him constructing his own crude
imitation of the illuminati citadel a
citadel and a sham judicial bureaucracy
of his own run by three puppets it's
just a theory now if you're keeping your
fingers crossed that the beanie baby
collection in your mom's attic is going
to regain its value and all of your
money concerns will be gone our friends
at truebill are here to help take some
of the pressure off of claude the crab
and patty the platypus truebill is an
all-in-one finance platform that helps
you save more and spend less the
personal finance manager allows you to
manage subscriptions lower bills monitor
your credit score and build your savings
all in one place i really like how easy
truebill makes it to safely and securely
identify recurring charges and cancel
unwanted subscriptions with just a tap
it's also got some nice credit score
monitoring tools to give you a little
nudge when something fishy might be
happening not fishy like bubbles a
beanie baby but you know like scammy
truebill helps set budgets that
automatically monitor your spending by
category get friendly notifications when
you've exceeded your budget and
visualize your spend to earn ratio over
time so get started with true build
today by heading to truebuild.com new
rockstars or by clicking the link in the
video's description that's truebuild.com
new rockstars next section
[Music]
we should tell him the truth
ooh baby yes one of the biggest reveals
in mcu history one that we will be
unpacking for months to come yes that
was the voice of patrick stewart
professor charles xavier in the fox
x-men films now in the marvel cinematic
universe as a member of what is almost
certain to be the illuminati now
marvel's illuminati is a secret alliance
of tony stark charles xavier reed
richards doctor strange black bolt and
namor black panther was initially gonna
be part of it but he backed out actually
in iron man 2 tony stark had a little
app on his phone labeled illuminati fun
little easter egg there but here the
illuminati if they will still go by that
name in the mcu seem to be serving as a
multiversal governing body with
representatives from across universes by
bringing fox x-men characters into this
they're building on the metal logic from
spider-man no way home marvel studios is
now adopting formerly separate cinematic
universes as mere universes within their
multiverse and expanding to the fox
x-men titles but if patrick stewart is a
representative from a separate reality
that could limit how much of that
separate reality we actually see in this
movie and which other fox x-men cameo
just yet like ian mckellen magneto hugh
jackman wolverine maybe maybe not but
ryan reynolds deadpool very likely as he
has been long confirmed to cross over to
the mcu and now that door has been
opened i mean this could also give us
some context finally to why evan peters
was cast as wanda's brother pietro in
her hex now yes the show producers did
say this is just a ralph boner joke but
the logic is all in place now we never
saw ralph after wanda's hex so it could
just be as simple as wanda's ability to
warp reality might have caused her to
pull the likeness of a pietro from the
nearest adjacent universe like if tom
holland peter parker were to die in the
mcu and juan maximoff wanted to create a
pocket reality where peter was alive
once more the peter in that hex might
look like andrew garfield if that makes
sense to you evan peters actually being
pietro from his fox x-men timeline
crossing over into juan division could
make an equal amount of sense now
meanwhile i don't know if this is the
charles xavier from the exact fox x-men
timeline whatever that was at the end of
that series because one thing that was
clear is that charles xavier died in the
year 2029 in logan after it was revealed
he accidentally killed all the x-men or
most of them i think it's likelier that
this charles could be from a branch
timeline within that universe because
time travel screwed up a lot of stuff
there let's be honest he actually could
be something closer to a live-action
version of the x-men 97 a version of
charles xavier that existed in the
branch timeline that eventually
discovered multiversal technology now
yes there are six chairs so let's try to
fill these chairs who they belong to two
of the figures are seated and one walks
in with a cane so i'm wondering if this
could be charles who in this form has
found his ability to walk once more now
the seated figure on the left wears a
form-fitting suit that you could say
looks a lot like the vibranium armor of
black panther and yes this illuminati
lineup may include a new actor playing a
variant t'challa however i think this
particular figure just looks a bit more
slender in the arms like reed richards
but that would also make it less likely
to be john krasinski yeah let's be
honest he's jacked ryan but let's slide
over to that other seated figure who is
hooded could this be sorcerer supreme
mordo or all reality photon or spectrum
monica rambo or were those ultron
centuries a clue that one member of this
panel is actually ultron infinity from
what if or that brilliant ship of
theseus white vision from one division
but my favorite version of this would be
this could be a reality in which tony
stark's ultron protocol actually
succeeded instead of turning on him
which led to him being able to evolve
into the superior iron man one played by
tom cruise
i mean we've heard this speculation for
years and now it just seems all possible
doesn't it but let's focus on what
charles actually says here we should
tell him the truth what truth the truth
that strange maybe didn't do anything
wrong or that him becoming a sorcerer
was a mistake or that all of this is
just some kang exposed sham organization
perhaps but i think the truth here is
that the mcu that we have loved all
these years is not the core reality of
this multiverse that instead we have
actually been living in an incomplete
post house of m reality where mutants
have been erased this whole time we just
didn't see it as anything wrong and now
it is time to fix that let's move on
[Music]
things just got out of hand okay some
real bonkers [ __ ] here doctor strange
and american chavez fall through a
reality with dinosaurs a t-rex fight a
triceratops but then to top that they
insanely smash into an animated cartoon
reality this could be one way doors open
to crossovers with what if this can
actually be how the animated captain
carter gets roped into this then strange
in america explode into cubic puzzle
pieces a visual that looks like a mix of
draxes reality stone hit and infinity
war and joe quesada's art of the scarlet
witch on the house of them variant cover
some of their blocks look like stones
from a statue and you can actually see
the rows of steven's individual teeth
still intact in his gums on each block
onto the next clip
[Music]
you break the rules look up
become a hero
i do it i become the enemy so yeah it
looks like wanda will invade illuminati
hq and get into a huge brawl with
someone who looks like they're going
binary the way captain marvel does but
if you look at that person closely this
is a woman of color now i know some of
you think this is tom cruise with a
goatee but that's just a contouring of
her cheeks tom cruise's figure is not
this womanly folks this is definitely
either monica rambo or her mother maria
rambo maria rambo's call sign was photon
and in the main mcu she died of cancer
during the blip but in one of vision
monica rambo powered up into the
superhero we assume will either be
photon or spectrum and the moment that
happened her body was split into several
alternate selves as she passed through
that hex wall and i think one of those
alternate selves could be this one we
are seeing now if you think about it
monica fighting wanda seems to be the
most epic collision considering these
two were both there for the battle of
west view in wanovision then we see the
attack on camertaj in the tea room that
we saw in the 2016 film including master
hamir returning from that film then a
close-up of america chavez gives a good
look at her wardrobe stars embroidered
on her jean jacket along with the phrase
amores amore love is love and flag pen
signaling some lgbtq plus representation
gargantos throws the bus with an ad on
the end for la llave coffee the key with
the tagline unlock a better day and then
over to the left the phone booth has an
ad for celestial tea the magic of tea
then i love this shot strange looks up
at another alternate sanctum with a
statue out front a statue that has no
facial hair though in this new york
greenery and oddly curved wind turbines
cover all the buildings and white
flowering trees line the streets trees
like the ones in wanda's fake orchard so
in strange's nightmare we saw the
darkest timeline here this looks like
the brightest timeline where a variant
strange has used his powers only to
better society moving on
that doesn't seem fair
[Music]
okay so interesting two wandas meet each
other and this is wanda's west view
house in one division you can see two
scooters in the background belonging to
her sons billy and tommy one of their
baseball gloves on the floor there but
this place is wrecked the staircase
handrail the blusters are broken as if
there was a fight between these two
wandas and the standing one is the one
who is barefoot yacht i actually wonder
if this kneeling wanda tried to recreate
the west view hex to have her children
once more but failed and now defeated
she's letting the darker side of her
identity take over if you think about it
the last time we saw her in one vision
her consciousness was split into two
conscious selves something people who
astrally project normally can't do there
was one in casual wear brewing tea and
then the other one in the scarlet witch
forum searching for her kids actively
now i'm wondering which of those two is
actually the deadlier threat the one
who's searching for her kids or the one
who's just sipping tea not giving up can
we see that shot again of morto striking
strange's cuffs now i'm wondering if
mortar might be doing this on purpose to
freeze strange so that strange can help
them fight this invading scarlet witch
but it might be too late because a huge
explosion from red chaos magic tears
through the hq leading to these
elaborate fireworks as we think rambo's
form gets blasted through that explosion
then this other sorcerer uses a sick
move with a lasso to attack gargantos
the tv spot actually showed american
chavez beneath this gross underbelly and
in these close-ups so you can see how
each of its tentacle suckers are
actually barbed with teeth ugh then this
gnarly shot of wanda aiming red chaos
magic she's at the doorway of illuminati
hq her face is bleeding like crazy and
separately she has black ink stains on
her shirt behind her in the distance
looks like one of the bells of camartage
perhaps after sacking that location and
holding her seance there she used that
to access the gateway to this compound
but why does she want to get in here
well when the camera zooms into her eye
there's a brief image of two holding
cells these are illuminati detention
cells dr strange was cuffed in one of
these and in the tv spot christine
palmer works among other techs who hold
america in another cell so i think the
reason wanda hasn't been able to find a
reality with their sons the reason why
her attempt to recreate west view didn't
work is that the illuminati are
detaining billy and tommy here in these
two cells and for wanda that's
especially infuriating because it's
exactly what hydra did to her and her
twin brother locking them up in adjacent
cells like in the comic house of m all
of this madness comes from a denial by
professor x and by doctor strange to
allow wanda reality with her children
and it's gonna end with wanda
drastically warping all that reality but
in this case i think a restoration of
mutants alongside avengers in the mcu on
to the final clips
[Applause]
so we end with a version of doctor
strange and wong on this snowy
mountaintop trying to reign in these
demonic figures these beans look like
they're actually made of the same inky
texture that the buildings and the other
surfaces are melting into as if this is
the chaos that it's all bleeding into
now the tv spot actually shows strange
facing another peak across the way with
some winged devil at the peak of it that
spot also shows a close-up of strange
whose face is rotting away looking a lot
like his zombie strange self and what if
episode v i pointed out because the tv
spot also includes a shot of wanda
looking especially zombie-like now while
zombie strange and that episode got
devoured by ants zombie wanda survived
and she returned in the final episode so
i don't know if these are zombies as
much as they're just animated corpses
but it is insane to see their souls so
strong that they can keep their bodies
intact long after their flesh should
have expired the final shot shows this
rotting strange blocking a rift into
darkness dozens of inky skeletons trying
to shove out past him skeleton arms fan
out behind him evoking the images of
icon pose that he formed when fighting
thanos infinity war now counteracting
that spell was the one time we saw the
soul stone being used in the mcu and i
find it interesting that strange's soul
is all he has left the film title comes
together from hundreds of pieces like
the shattering and reassembling shards
of reality in this movie but this is the
third title design we've seen it's
almost like the studio wants us to
constantly reframe the reality in which
we see this movie every time they talk
about it so folks you've got to check
out our new merch options including two
sick mephisto designs at new
rockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at you boss follow
new rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you